Heure sonne matin
Pleure chagrin
Et repasse le film humide
Du passé dans les yeux
Court bien trop court
Notre amour, et les appels
Au secours savent qu'un sourd
N'entend pas ce qu'il veut
Et pourtant il veut vivre
Ou survivre
Sans poème
Sans blesser tous ceux qui l'aiment
Être heureux
Malheureux
Vivre seul ou même à deux
Mais vivre pour toujours
Sans discours sans velours
Sans les phrases inutiles
D'un vieux roman photo
Fleurs fanées meurent
Noir et blanc
Seules couleurs d'un futur
Qui est déjà le passé pour nous deux
Et pourtant il faut vivre
Ou survivre
Sans poème
Sans blesser tous ceux qu'on aime
Être heureux
Malheureux
Vivre seul ou même à deux
Et pourtant il faut vivre
Ou survivre
Sans poème
Sans blesser ceux qui nous aiment
Être heureux
Malheureux
Vivre seul ou même à deux
Mais vivre en silence
En pensant aux souffrances
De la terre et se dire
Qu'on n’est pas les plus malheureux
Mais quand dans l'amour
Tout s'effondre
Toute la misère du monde
N'est rien à côté d'un adieu
Et pourtant je veux vivre
Ou survivre
Sans poème
Sans blesser tous ceux que j'aime
Être heureux
Malheureux
Vivre seul ou même à deux
Vivre ou survivre
Seul ou meme à deux